we're in a fight boys are doing all that  you can do anybody can see that a world  full of hate  with the compassion with restraint and  generosity  [Music]  you know  as a team  we're gonna crumble  our lives are not fully lived  if we're not willing to Die For What We  Believe  they're bigger faster stronger more  experienced and on paper they're just  better and they know it too I want to  tell you something that they don't know  they don't know your heart  we can't be consumed by a petty  differences anymore we will be United in  our common interest nothing will come  between us and that's a vision of a  world United  and most importantly you must always  have faith in yourself